[Música]
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y el mundo aquí en tras 24 mi
nombre es liviana valencia y empezamos
en haití porque fue asignado el
presidente de job en el mois en la
madrugada de este miércoles según un
comunicado del hasta hace poco primer
ministro interino claude joseph el
aeropuerto de puerto príncipe en la
capital fue cerrado tras el crimen según
informaron fuentes diplomáticas según el
comunicado un grupo de individuos no
identificados atacó la residencia
privada del presidente de la república y
lo hirió con armas de fuego causándole
la muerte
eeuu calificó como un trágico ataque el
que acabó con la vida del mandatario
haitiano el primer ministro interino de
haití y el consejo superior de la
policía nacional hicieron un llamado a
la calma asegurando que la situación de
seguridad del país está controlada por
las fuerzas armadas yo en el móvil tomó
posesión como presidente de haití el 7
de febrero de 2017 pero desde 2019 la
ciudadanía venía manifestando
inconformidad con su gobierno y pidiendo
su renuncia con protestas
current es la primera dama martín
maurice resultó también herida de bala
durante el asalto y se encuentra
hospitalizada según el comunicado
oficial aunque se espera actualización
de esta información
el presidente haití yo en el mois nació
el 26 de junio de 1968 18 5 años al
mando del país caribeño en medio de un
contexto de inestabilidad política y
social entonces tenemos aquí en 24 más
información para ustedes y tenemos
invitados tenemos análisis a esta hora y
también un perfil político y un perfil
también de la vida de yo en el móvil que
lo prepara alva santana vamos sólo a
continuación hasta el 2015 el exportador
de plátano siempre serio joven el mois
él nunca había ocupado un cargo político
año en el que a pesar de ser poco
conocido por el público general el
haitiano se lanzó como candidato a la
presidencia con el partido ph teca una
opción de centro derecha el empresario
consiguió ganar las elecciones generales
del octubre de ese año con el 32 8% de
los votos
pero los comicios fueron invalidados por
irregularidades y no fue hasta febrero
de 2017 que lleven el mouse juró el
cargo y se convirtió en el presidente
del país más pobre de américa desde
entonces
haití ya se estaba encaminando hacia una
crisis política y social que no le
pondría las cosas fáciles al recién
nombrado mandatario con miles de
personas en las calles desde mediados de
2018 la crisis alcanzó su punto álgido
el 7 de febrero de este año cuando el
dirigente acusó a la oposición de estar
tramando un golpe de estado con el apoyo
de algunos jueces sus desertores
sostenían que su mandato terminaba en
febrero de 2021 apoyándose en que éste
había empezado antes de jurar el cargo
en medio de una época políticamente
convulsa haití enfrenta un gran problema
de seguridad el poder de las bandas
criminales ha aumentado con la crisis
política y los índices de secuestros y
la criminalidad están disparados por eso
es intento frenar el descontento social
y las protestas impulsando un referendo
para votar una nueva constitución
próximo 26 de septiembre y buscó apoyos
internacionales como el de eeuu para
permanecer en la presidencia el político
de 53 años terminaba su mandato en
febrero de 2022 y es que haití
justamente se preparaba para unas
elecciones generales el próximo mes de
septiembre y para renovar el mandato
presidencial a partir de febrero del
próximo año esto deja el país en un
nuevo estado de inestabilidad que
profundiza la crisis que ya venía desde
hace varios años a nivel social político
y por supuesto económico además en medio
de la pandemia de kobe 19 para dejar
esta información nos acompaña nuevamente
el señor luis jean pierre louis son
doctor en ciencias políticas y
administración pública gracias por estar
con nosotros de nuevo aquí en france 24
y cuéntanos haití enfrenta como ya
decíamos una profunda crisis económica
social y política además de la pandemia
de ccoo 19 que le espera al país tras el
asesinato del presidente yo en el móvil
tristemente castillo castillo la
violencia está viendo actualmente y ni
la violencia que usted va a venir en
nuestros días porque ya muchos mensajes
de parte de las personas mismos que de
pronto que asesinaron al presidente y lo
que creo que el papel de estados unidos
va a ser muy fundamental muy importante
en esta resolución de esta crisis por lo
que lo que llega a eeuu es lo que se
hace en haití es si alguien creía que
está pasando en haití en eeuu este punto
no tiene más o menos un poquito de
control sobre la situación sería un
poquito de prudente pero yo ellos están
haciendo todo lo posible para que las
postas se vuelven han logrado la
normalidad porque es lo que se hablaba
que las tropas de eeuu estaban como
listo para moverse el aire
bueno también cuéntenos según la
legislación haitiana quién debería
suceder al presidente en caso de una
muerte repentina sabemos que un primer
ministro nuevo fue nombrado apenas este
lunes sabemos que también podría ser
alguno de los altos mandos de la rama
judicial pero entonces cuál es el orden
de acuerdo a la constitución haitiana
que se debe seguir en un caso como éste
que por supuesto es atípico
normalmente el huésped del fortis
es uno de ellos que debería poder pero
si usted mira bien el comunicado que
sacaron aunque el primer ministro no
estaba en funciones expone que nombraron
un nuevo primer ministro
entonces el comunicado de calmar los
ánimos en la calle los tacos el consejo
superior de seguridad que hace parte del
gol del primer ministro antes desde el
ministro que colocaron o sea claudio sea
éste al que está con el comunicado está
el que le tomó otra vez el otro supuesto
en el país
bueno y además de eso también cuéntenos
qué papel puede jugar entonces la
comunidad internacional yo se nos
hablaba un poco de lo que puede pasar
acerca de eeuu pero recordemos que haití
es un caso atípico también creo que es
de las pocas islas a nivel mundial que
está compartida por dos países la isla
de quisqueya en el caribe americano por
supuesto y en este país se encuentran
dos naciones por un lado república
dominicana por otro lado haití son
acciones muy distintas república
dominicana que habla español haití que
habla francés y unos conflictos entre
ambas naciones también históricos pero
agravados por un tema fronterizo y
migratorio así que más allá de eeuu que
va a haber pues jugar la comunidad
internacional por supuesto francia y la
pronunciarse acerca del asesinato de
ello en el mois américa latina por
ejemplo y nos confirma ya hasta ahora
que república dominicana cerró fronteras
también me imagino que con un ánimo de
evitar que se generen de pronto fugas o
controlar la migración y evita también
nuevos roces porque en el comunicado se
argumenta que los asesinos hablaban
español entonces en términos
internacionales que les espera
adelante también acerca de este hecho
acerca de esta hecho yo no creo que de
las expectativas no lucen muy altas
porque lo que pasó anoche es muy grave
es muy grave y asesinar al presidente
pero por supuesto el terremoto también
era muy grave entonces el mismo
terremoto si usted mira la comunidad
internacional ayudó mucho durante el
terremoto pero todo esto no sabemos
dónde se supone que estos puntos eran
para ayudar a las víctimas del terremoto
pero estos fondos normalmente vuelven a
los mismos países que le según varias
investigaciones vuelven a los países que
manejaban estos fondos si usted mira
bien en las campañas electorales está de
eeuu en que irá al clinton in donación
por por su es cierto derecha siempre
acusaba a los clinton y todo el mundo en
aquí saben que hubo cosas que fueron mal
y mal hechas
qué pasa las expectativas de los
haitianos en este momento es una zozobra
la gente no saben qué hacer la gente
corren por donde sea yo hablé con mucha
gente pero es muchas veces está la gente
no tiene en la comunidad internacional
lo que tiene que hacer es acudir a la
clase intelectual en la actividad clase
dirigente si es que existe todavía una
clase dirigente y tratar de fortalecer
las instituciones es lo más importante
las instituciones y si no si fracasan en
haití van a fracasar en muchos países
bueno pues usted mencionaba justamente
el terremoto de haití en el año 2010 que
tuvo lugar el 12 de enero de ese año y
que ocasionó por supuesto una crisis
humanitaria a la ciudad puerto príncipe
quedó devastada en ese momento hubo
muchísimos muertos muchísimos
damnificados y una infraestructura ya
debilitada quedó nuevamente otra vez
casi que para reconstruir el país tuvo
una muy muy lenta recuperación casi 10
años después en 2020 aún había mucha
familia sin hogar en puerto príncipe y
otros poblados aledaños a esto se suma
también una epidemia de cólera posterior
y además de eso ahorita la pandemia de
kobe 19 en un país que es el único del
continente que no ha recibido ni
siquiera una dosis de los antídotos
contra el virus entonces tenemos un
contexto complicado un contexto que
además podría darle haití también una
base para reconstruir la
institucionalidad como usted mismo lo
dice que podría entonces pasar o que
enfrentaría el nuevo presidente de adif
y más bien en los próximos años si se
consigue mantiene el calendario
electoral si las elecciones generales en
septiembre que podría enfrentar o cuál
serían los principales retos
el próximo presidente de haití
los últimos años en haití
la plastia diligente like y ellos que
quieren gobiernos adicionales los
productos que quieren esto porque esto
cuando hacen mayor fortuna ahora bien
que se esté hay un presidente en haití
van a contar lo mismo
el presidente difunto actualmente porque
por cambiar las cosas por componer y la
electricidad del país está en manos de
un privado que cobraba dado cuántos
millones de dólares nunca ahora ya son
esos temas que son del había tocado y
también hay uno
lo que no voy a dar su nombre también en
los últimos días los dos días sabía
cuántas que había problema de que lo
estaban cita y se justamente una ciudad
del asesinato del cierto ya que ver con
esto pero todo la cama en donde una muy
poco es millonario
esto es lo que cualquier nuevo
claro pues agradecemos a nuestro
invitado y queremos contarle la
audiencia que está llegando información
constante nuevas confirmaciones de
noticias a raíz del asesinato del
presidente de haití yo en el móvil
confirmamos aquí en nuestro sistema el
cierre inmediato de fronteras decretado
por el gobierno de república dominicana
país vecino de haití y además de eso
pues reacciones por ejemplo de países
como eeuu que han calificado el
asesinato de yo en el mois como un
terrible ataque como un trágico ataque
el presidente giovanni la casa blanca
han asegurado que van a esperar más
información antes de hacer un
pronunciamiento oficial pero desde ya
lamentan el asesinato del joven el mois
también más temprano estuvo con nosotros
ricardo seitenfus profesor universitario
y ex presidente representante de la oea
en haití de los años 2009 y 2011 a quien
le preguntamos también sobre el papel de
la comunidad internacional en este en
esos hechos que están ocurriendo durante
esta jornada en haití esto por lo que
nos dijo
no es el modus operandi de la política
violenta política y yo no creo que sean
las manillas yo creo que son grupos
mucho más organizados más importantes y
el rol de estados unidos para descubrir
esto es fundamental la gente va a querer
saber quién lo mandó ahora la primera
cosa hacer en nombre del presidente
acuerde su problema como presidente y
progresar
yo si fuera consejero de el gobierno
diciendo diría vamos a mantener todo el
calendario como el presidente rubén en
el consejo electoral propuso o sea
direcciones generales fines de
septiembre referendo
hasta febrero del año próximo
un nuevo presidente la presidenta y el
poder
yo no no cambiaría en nada de nada el
calendario
yo conocí a jóvenes y siempre me pareció
un anti político no una persona que
venir del campo un empresario no conocía
los dos los caminos de la república que
puedan de puerto príncipe con la llama
del poder que se concentra en la capital
del país pero mucha cola nuestros
parajes físicas
yo hablé con algunos asexuales de
difuminar el presidente tener cuidado
pero nunca se imaginaba que los asesinos
iban a sancionar la democracia y tierra
en plena residencia presidencial es una
cosa inédita en los parámetros y los
cánones latinoamericanas se asocian a un
recurso el coche y el palacio y una
manifestación pero no de la casa
particular demandas de nuestra cadena
hermana france24 en inglés habló con el
ex embajador de francia en haití didier
le white
esto decía sobre lo que podría pasar en
el país tras el asesinato del presidente
yo en el móvil en la madrugada de anoche
ah
no hay nada que pueda interpretarse de
la actual constitución no hay un
presidente del tribunal de casación ni
primer ministro nombrado oficialmente
por lo que habrá una transición que
podría desembocar en cierta violencia si
no se hace nada para evitarlo desde el
principio esta es una de las opciones y
eso requerirá que las naciones amigas
ayuden rápidamente con todo lo que
puedan no debemos dejar haití abandonada
en este momento desgraciadamente yo en
el móvil no ha acertado en absoluto como
presidente tendría que haber escuchado
al pueblo antes que la violencia llegar
a ese nivel no creo que haya sido un
mandato muy exitoso
una parte de sus enemigos en la gente
que se sentía traicionada y que quería
encontrar alguna forma de organizar
elecciones y deshacerse de un poder que
estaba lejos de ser legítimo
a lo largo de la programación de france
24 continuaremos informando los detalles
acerca del asesinato del presidente de
haití job en el móvil y otras noticias
debe acontecer internacional nos vemos
más adelante con más información